more tension in the eastern
Mediterranean as Cyprus accuses turkey
of using stolen data to position a
drilling ship similar to this one
precisely on top of the potential gas
field in its waters Greece too is
bracing for the potential appearance of
Turkish exploration vessels in waters
east of Crete and it's threatening to
sink them yes
turkey could have joined Egypt Israel
Greece and Cyprus in the East made gas
forum to develop gas fields but has
chosen instead to be a habitual
transgressor of international law the
East met gas forum countries are
planning to build a 2000 kilometre
pipeline to sell gas to Europe Turkey
has reacted by drilling in Cypriot
waters without Cyprus permission and
threatening to do the same in Greek
waters last year Turkey and Libya marked
out a corridor of territorial water
claimed by Greece raising tension
further can tricky sustain such an
ambitious foreign policy that is at the
same time adventurous has opportunistic
dangerous and not fully in supported or
not at all actually supported by most of
the great powers I think that this will
not end very well that's my prediction
for the future if you go by the book by
the United Nations note of the book that
pipeline passes through Turkish maritime
zones and they could sit down and tell
them we have a portion of I don't know
200 miles of 100 miles that crosses this
like turkey is already a major transit
land wise of many pipelines
could also a major transit point
offshore if it is built the pipeline
will carry about 2% of the gas Europe
consumes and might manage 4% it isn't a
game-changer Europe will still rely on
Russia for about 40% of its gas but it
would be a political statement that
Europe wants pipelines built by
Europeans that cross European territory
marking out territory though is the
problem Turkey has not signed the
international law of the sea and claims
areas of the Mediterranean that Greece
and Cyprus also claim under that law
Europe denounces the Turkish view as
illegal but that doesn't seem to be
deterring Turkey and tension is set to
rise further jumps our applause al
Jazeera Athens